Good morning. Hank. It's Tuesday.
I'm still on vacation, but don't worry I brought
35,000 sheets of paper with me.
And as you can see here, I've signed very nearly 120,000 sheets.
Today, I thought I'd answer some real questions from
real Nerdfighters about signing.
Beginning with: Are you literally signing
200,000 sheets of paper?
Yes, so I sign all of these sheets.
And then I send them to Pennsylvania
where they are bound one-by-one
into copies of my new book, 𝑇𝑢𝑟𝑡𝑙𝑒𝑠 𝐴𝑙𝑙 𝑡𝘩𝑒 𝑊𝑎𝑦 𝐷𝑜𝑤𝑛.
And because the book obviously has to be printed somewhat in advance
of its publication on October 10th,
I have to finish signing by, like, August 17th.
Are you aware that your signature is currently
worth negative four dollars on Amazon?
Yeah, I actually think it's negative three dollars
at the moment,
but it's true that the signed edition
is currently less expensive than the unsigned one.
I get the same royalty regardless
and have no control over Amazon's discounting.
But also Amazon might be onto something
because for like a year after 𝘛𝘩𝘦 𝘍𝘢𝘶𝘭𝘵 𝘪𝘯 𝘖𝘶𝘳 𝘚𝘵𝘢𝘳𝘴 came out,
unsigned copies were much rarer than signed ones.
How many paper cuts have you gotten so far?
Amazingly, none yet.
But I spend a lot of time worrying about it.
Why two hundred thousand?
Uh...at the time it seemed like enough,
but not too much.
Why u do dis?
To be honest, I'm not totally sure,
but I do have some theories.
One reason is that it's always struck me as unfair
that people who don't live near major Metropolitan Areas
or for whatever reason can't go to author events
don't get signed books unless they pay a surcharge.
But there are also a lot of selfish reasons,
one of which is that you know like
for the last 2000 days or so,
I've been trying to write this book,
and on most of those days
I didn't know if what I was writing
would ever make it into the book.
A lot of those days I couldn't even
tell if the work I was doing
was getting me closer to a book I was proud of
or further away from it.
With this I know that I'm doing something people will like,
and each time I do it,
I get a little closer to being done;
writing is not like that for me.
Does your hand hurt?
No, I got some incredibly effective physical therapy
when I was doing this for 𝘛𝘩𝘦 𝘍𝘢𝘶𝘭𝘵 𝘪𝘯 𝘖𝘶𝘳 𝘚𝘵𝘢𝘳𝘴
because I have Ulnar Nerve Entrapment,
and since then I've been able to just sign all day.
Why don't you hire someone to make a machine
that perfectly mimics your signature?
You know there are some jobs
that robots just can't do, and
one of them is monotonously
creating the same scratch on a page
two hundred thousand times.
How consistent does your signature tend to be?
So I think it varies wildly,
but Sarah thinks I just spend way too much time
looking at my signature.
I've grabbed three here that I think are very different
to give you a sense of the variation.
How many papers can you sign in an hour?
It takes about two hours to do a thousand,
so in total this project is gonna to take
around 400 hours.
Would you please put that pen to work on another book
instead of a zillion fairly anonymous tokens?
No, see the problem is the pen does
not want to work on another book.
What kind of pen are you using?
I use Sharpies and lots of them.
I'm in something of a blue period by the way.
Are you sponsored by Sharpie?
No, I wish!
I'm ready to sell out for some of that
sweet sweet Sharpie money.
But no, I buy my Sharpies.
How do you decide what colors to sign in?
Well, you're deciding the color breakdown
at the last hundred thousand.
Thanks to your votes
Do you ever write or draw random things
in some of the books along with your signature?
Yes, for reasons that will become obvious to
readers of the book, I sometimes make a spiral.
What good media have you been
enjoying while signing?
I'm mostly listening to podcasts including all of these,
but I also listen to Pride and Prejudice on audiobook
and it is still great
What's your rhythm?
Pull-play-sign-pass?
I guess my rhythm looks approximately like this,
and then once that done pile gets big enough,
I stack them and start again.
Can you draw turtles all the way down on mine?
No, but I did draw signatures
all the way down on this one.
What are some interesting thoughts
you've had during this process?
I would actually say the chief pleasure of it
is that I don't have very many thoughts at all.
When you first started signing the books,
did you think it was fun?
I honestly still think it's fun.
Where can I buy the book?
Somebody knows how to ensure their
question gets answered!
The signed edition has its own ISBN.
There are links in the doobly-doo below.
But also pretty much wherever books are sold.
And lastly,
can I Hanklerfish some?
Hank, I'll be putting this box in the mail shortly.
I'll see you on Friday.